في منطقه السواره متواجدين في هذه الاثناء
حيث اغارت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
على هذه البنايه حيث هناك عدد من الاصابات
والاضرار والشهداء جراء هذه الغاره
الاسرائيليه في منطقه السواره غرب مخيم
النصيرات حيث ضربت هذه الطائرات عده شقق
سكنيه للمواطنين الامنين في تلك المنطقه
منطقه السوح الى الغرب من مخيم النصيرات
اذا هذه البنايه التي تم قصفها حيث يقوم
المواطنين بجمع اشلاء الشهداء الذين تم
نقلهم للمستشفى في مدينه دير البلح حيث
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه منذ ايام
وهي تكثف غاراتها الجويه على مخيم
النصيرات ومخيمات المحافظه الوسطى بشكل
عام المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
ايضا تقصف وبقوه منطقه مخيم النصيرات وسط
قطاع غزه في اطار عمليه التقدم البري في
هذا المحور وهو محور مخيم النصيرات ومحور
مخيم البريج بالاضافه ايضا للغارات الجويه
الاسرائيليه التي تستهدف منازل المواطنين
في مخيم المغازي خلال الساعات الاخيره ط
محمد ابو قريب ابن عمه ابو احمد راجل موظف
مالوش في شي موظف سلطه مهندس زراعي اولاده
قاعدين في الدار فيش عندهم حاجه ولا حاجه
يجيهم الصاروخ هيك مراته ابنه كلهم
استشهدوا هي قطع هي بنلم فيهم قطع يعني
بضي حدا هذا اللي بصير في الناس حرام حرام
حرام اللي بصير في العالم هذا اي ما في
حدا مطلع عنا حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل
حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل ما بنقول اكثر غير
من هيك ايش نسوي بدون سابق انظار ب صاروخ
هي صاروخ هي صاروخين البيت دمروه على اهله
كلهم عنده ناس جماته ونازحين شهداء ثلاثه
وجرحى فوق العدد عارفين اي صار عندهم اي
انت شايف بموا في قطع اللحم والغاره دمرت
طابقا كاملا كما تشاهدون في هذه الاوقات
والدمار قد حل بشكل كامل ايضا في محيط
المنطقه وفي منازل المواطنين المجاوره
لهذه البنايه التي دمرتها الصواريخ
الاسرائيليه من الطائرات الحربيه الاف 16
كما ذكر شهود العيال لنا بان الغاره كانت
قويه وعنيفه جدا في هذه
المنطقه هذا المنزل كان بداخلها ايضا
اعداد من الاسر النازحه من مناطق التي
تشهد عمليات قصف مستمره في المناطق
الشرقيه لمخيم النصيرات ومنطقه شرق منطقه
الزوايده حيث لجوا لدى اقربائهم هنا هذه
الغار الجديده على مخيم النصيرات
وبالتحديد على غرب مخيم النصيرات على
منطقه السواره خلفت اعداد من الشهداء
والمصابين تم نقلهم للمستشفيات ولكن
الغارات الاسرائيليه مستمره على وسط قطاع
غزه وبكثافة
قطاع اشرف ابو عمره لقناه الجزيره مخيم
النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه